well bridging the home ownership gap
between african americans and other
races
it's a it's an issue still very
prevalent here in our country and right
here in the valley
but some of the brightest minds are
coming together this weekend to address
it
madison kimbrough shows us what to
expect
for blacks we're about 35 percent of all
blacks own a home
whereas for whites it's 62 percent so
there's the gap
this saturday the make homes possible
coalition is hosting a live
online webinar speaking on this exact
topic it's called master class on
building black wealth with home
ownership this master class that we're
hosting on saturday
we're going to teach the process to home
ownership we're also going to teach how
to get access to
up to 25 thousand dollars in down
payment assistance even if you aren't
ready to buy a home the master class
will provide knowledge and resources for
you to use in the future
homeownership is the heart of the
american dream right
where we live where we get to raise our
kids it affects you know our health our
safety
it affects our communities at its core
and so that's why it's so important
creates a
vicious cycle when generations of
families are kept out of home ownership
the urban chamber of commerce nevada
housing division and the city of las
vegas are all in partnership with this
event
set to launch at 10 a.m this saturday
you can register at
makehomespossible.org
madison kimbrough 8 news now well as of
now the master class has more than a
thousand people registered but there are
still some open spots
we have all that information on our
website 8newsnow.com